I watched the Dick Van Dyke Show and I
thought oh my god it's so much fun they
do skits for each other they perform
there's a piano Maury Amsterdam's there
what a blast and then I went and I
became a cop you were in The Simpsons
and we would sit around on the radiused
couch ever invented in the world the
radiused
and everyone would just sit there John
Swart folder would smoke and people
would spend hours thinking of one line
for Bart the room filling with smoke and
I thought where's the piano where's the
dancing so I got up and did that stuff
and they threw me out they threw you out
to a good place yeah they did they did
how did you come up with that idea
how did you decide because you had had
so much success with sid caesar on your
Stroeve shows then you create this show
the Dick Van Dyke Show what gave you the
inspiration to create that well you know
right after the show of shows have nine
years with sid caesar doing sketches
sketch comedy disappeared on until carol
burnett brought it back back but i was
being offered situation comedies and
westerns were the big things at their
time and so i read a few of these and
they weren't very good and my wife and
her infinite wisdom said why don't you
write one and i don't know so one summer
in Fire Island I wrote a thing called
head of the family
and Peter Lawford put up the money for
me to do a pilot and I said oh if I'm
going to do a pilot I better have some
scripts so that summer in six weeks I
wrote 13 episodes of head of the family
I did the pilot and you were the star I
was the star girl named Barbara Britton
Morty kunti and Sylvia miles played the
two other carats it was okay it was just
okay and it didn't work so I went on I
started writing some pictures for Doris
Day for a universe I was having a good
time but my agent Harry couch and I'm
bless him he couldn't stand the fact
that were 13 episodes lying on his desk
gold he could sell and I he called me
and he got Sheldon Leonard and Danny
Thomas who had a company a time till the
Tal productions they said we're
interested in your show and I said I
said fellas I don't want to fail with
the same material twice and Sheldon said
to me and this is a pretty good
impression of him he won't fail because
we'll get a better actor to play you
[Applause]
they got big bad guy he mentioned Dick
Van Dyke I went to see him in New York
and Bye Bye Birdie and best situation
comedian than the history of the world
and Mary Tyler Moore was another thing I
said the Sheldon well I saw 26 girls
literally crazy I couldn't
I said Sheldon I can't find the girl
that wife Laurie says you'll know when
you find it you'll know when you see it
this girl came in Mary Tyler Moore
looking like Mary Tyler Moore great gams
beautiful girl and I tell ya you don't
get to say that anymore but I love em
well this was way back then when we act
like that the bowling pins not one
anyway
hi I I said I gave her a piece of script
to read and she read the first line and
had a ping in her voice yeah and I I did
this I made my hand like a claw I like
the machine in the in the carnival's you
know they get candy out of things I went
across the room I went through a head
and I read the top of her head and I
said come with me and I walked her down
the hall to Sheldon like I found her
yeah that was it that's another thing
we're not allowed to do anymore